Okay this morning we are going to have
finished talking about marks and we're
going to focus on the failures of Marxism
and the legacies of Marxism and the
failures are connected to the legacies
and important ways that will unfold as we
proceed with today's discussion.
I began this already on Monday by talking
about the difficulties with Marx's
assumptions about scarcity and super
abundance and we saw that just as male
couldn't banish politics from the,
from politics through the mechanism
of a neutral definition of harm.
Mark's is unable to banish politics from
politics by somehow wishing of conflict
could in principle go away.
We saw that that notion of super abundance
that informs his communist new Utopia
is incoherent in principle and that means
that distributive conflict is endemic
to human society.
No matter how much wealth there is and
some principles for the distribution of
income and wealth are going to have to
be argued about and defended regardless
of what is produced in society or
what could be produced in society.
The second failure of
Marxism as well known,
but we should nonetheless mention it,
which is that his,
his historical predictions turned out
to be hopelessly wide of the mark.
Not only was he wrong in 1830 and 1848
when he thought the communist revolutions
were about to sweep through Europe.
Um,
they were both a not communist and
be quickly reversed. In any event,
uh, within a couple of years, um,
his larger historical predictions were,
were also wrong.
He thought Communism would come socialist
revolutions for reasons that you now
know because we've worked
through the macro theory,
he thought that socialist revolutions
would occur in advanced capitalist systems
that had become uncompetitive because
of the replacement of competitive
capitalism with, with capitalism,
with monopoly capitalism. And in fact,
where we saw revolutions bearing the
Communists label was in peasant societies
and in Russia and in China, um, or in,
in eastern Europe,
in countries where it was actually more
or less imposed from the outside, um,
by the Soviet Union after World War Two,
we didn't really see any
society go through the sort
of path march was thinking
of and his larger teleological
theory of history,
namely from feudalism to capitalism
to socialism to communism,
it simply didn't happen.
And as the reversals of the
revolutions of 1830 and 1848,
uh,
remind us on a smaller scale,
Mark's is bigger idea that there's some
purpose or direction to history seems
questionable by the first
decades of the 21st century.
History doesn't go in a single direction.
Um,
and this is a theme to which we
will return, but you can see, um,
movements toward more egalitarian
systems and then movements away from
egalitarian systems.
You can see democracy created and
then you can see it collapse into
authoritarianism so that there
isn't a single TV or logical,
uh,
or direction or focus of history of
the sort that march was looking for.
So on the big,
big predictions,
Marxism doesn't look very good from
the vantage point of the 21st century,
but some of his smaller
predictions were also wrong, uh,
in ways that in some, some respects
more interesting for our purposes.
And so I'm going to go back through,
um,
some of his arguments and focus on things
that were wrong with those arguments
that we can nonetheless,
George some interesting conclusions about
as we go on our way and examining the
moral foundations of politics.
And,
and I'm going to start with his macro
theory and talk about some difficulties
with that. And then I'm going to go
backwards into the micros theory.
So we're doing the reverse, if you
like, of what we did on the way in,
we started with the micro theory and we
saw how that generated the macro theory.
Now we're going backwards through the
macro theory and then we will go back into
the labor theory of value
and the assumptions about
workmanship that underlie it
that he took over from Loc and
secularized and modernized. As you know,
so if you'll recall from Monday's lecture
Marxists macro theory was an invisible
hand theory like Smith's,
except it was a malevolent invisible hand
where a Smith's was a benign invisible
hand,
and one element of it was that argument
about the potential for liquidity
crises,
that there would be the possibility
that people would hoard money,
that money would stop flowing through
the system and the system would thereby
become sclerotic.
It isn't.
It is the case that capitalist systems
have the potential for liquidity crises,
but one of the things Mark's greatly
underestimated was the capacity of
capitalists states in
capitalist societies,
states in capitalist societies to address
things like liquidity crises and other
things as well.
We'll see.
It's almost as if he didn't really take
it seriously when he and angles said in
the communist manifesto that the state
in capitalist society is the executive
committee of the bourgeoisie.
He underestimated what the state could
actually do to preserve capitalism.
Um,
a good example in the early years of
this system was lik huge liquidity crisis
in Mexico where,
uh,
the whole Mexico Mexican economy was
on the verge of complete collapse.
But the western governments led by the,
the United States put together a
$50 billion package to resolve that,
to pump liquidity into the Mexican
economy until the crisis was over and they
succeeded.
And so we didn't see the kind of collapse
in the maximum Mexican economy that
that liquidity crisis, uh,
had the potential to create.
So the,
the argument about the potential
for liquidity crises is valid,
but we have no particular reason
to think they can't be managed.
Once the sources of liquidity crises
are understood and governments have the
levers available to
them, uh, that were, uh,
made available to the Mexican
government in, in the, uh,
during the Clinton administration
in the US. Secondly,
Mark's has this argument about the
declining tendency in the rate of profit.
As I said to you,
every classical political
economists believe that there
was a declining tendency
in the rate of profit in market systems
and they thought one of their jobs was
to account for it.
They thought it was definitely the case
that there is this phenomenon and you
had to explain why it occurs.
It's in fact,
if we look over the long course of
capitalism since the 19th century,
it's far from clear that there
is as an empirical matter,
a longterm declining tendency
in the rate of profit.
Um, in Marx's case, uh, as you know,
his story about the declining tendency
and the rate of profit had to do with the
increasing capital intensity
of production that,
um,
as capitalists compete by,
uh,
relying more and more on what
he calls constant capital.
Um,
there's less and less fresh value created.
And so what capitalists entrepreneurs do
at the margin to be more competitive in
the long run to more profitable in the
medium run, makes them less profitable.
So the capitalists who puts the Spinning
Jenny and increases his profits in the
short run,
but when they're spinning jennies in
every cotton factory in the economy,
the rate of profit is lower than before
the first spinning Jenny had been put in.
And Mark's identified that as the basic
dynamic driving the declining tendency
in the rate of profit.
Two problems with it.
Okay.
One is
that it is,
so there's a sort of finite number
of industries because you could say,
you could grant his argument
and say, yeah, it's,
it's true that the rate of profit in the
cotton industry will fall as it becomes
more and more capital intensive.
But there are all kinds of new industries
that are going to come into being all
the time.
So capital will flow eventually into other
industries and they'll start out with
big profit margins and then the
profit margins will get competed away.
But then capital level
goes somewhere else.
So unless you have this idea that this
is sort of fixed number of lines of
production
such that that once profit
start to fall in all of them,
I'm not going gonna fall economy.
Why there's no particular reason,
even working from Marx's on premises to
think that has come up with any lasting
account of why the rate of profit
would fall in capitalist systems.
Moreover,
even putting that problem to one side,
if you think about it,
if it is the case,
okay,
even if it is the case
that making capital, uh,
pro production more capital intensive
reduces profit margins in the long run.
Nonetheless,
if productivity goes up at a more rapid
rate than capital displaces labor in the
production process,
then you wouldn't necessarily
see the right of profit fall.
So if,
if the rate of increase in productivity
exceeds the rate at which capital is
displacing label,
put it in Marx's jargon,
constant capitalist,
displacing variable capital,
then there's actually no reason to expect,
um,
the rate of profit to fall.
So it all depends on how much more
productive capitol makes Labor.
And there's no theoretical answer to that
question. It's an empirical question.
So, even though I'm Marx thought there
was a declining tendency in the rate of
profit,
it's debatable whether in fact there is,
and it's certainly not the case that his
theory explained why it should occur.
Okay.
His third argument,
competition,
LM and eight competitors.
And because production is becoming
more and more capital intensive,
entry costs are going up and you're not
going to see new people coming into the
market.
Okay?
I told the story about,
uh,
NASA and the o rings on the
challenge of blowing up.
There was nobody to come
into the market and, uh, uh,
take over dad's.
So you have a monopoly,
not very efficient monopoly producer,
um,
uh,
who lacks the incentive to innovate and
we have the sorts of problems we saw
that developed with Morton
Thiokol in that instance.
So that's also true,
only under a fairly
restrictive set of assumptions,
which might not turn out
to be true after all.
There are some industries in which
there are economies of smallness.
Think about apple computers invented
in somebody's garage in California,
um,
you know,
completely upending IBM and the big
established capital-intensive computer
firms. Uh, and totally
transforming that market.
So it's not necessarily true.
You know, Mark's had in his mind,
19th century industrial
production, uh, you know,
steelworks cotton factories,
this sort of thing.
But it's a very historically bounded
perception of what it is that goes on in,
in,
in economic systems.
And there might be all sorts of sectors
in the economy that tend to resist the
development of monopolies and in which
there are various economies of smallness
that actually lend themselves to
the constant entry of new players,
uh, that he provided. Realizing
the system. And I think the, the,
the information technology
revolution that, uh,
of that is accompanied your
generation would be exhibit a in,
uh,
defending that proposition
under consumption or sometimes it's said
overproduction obviously means the same
thing.
You know,
the way we put it into Marx's sort of
conceptual scheme was the argument that
the workers collectively couldn't
buy everything they produced.
A Smith believed that
Ricardo believed that.
Marx believed that an early theories
of imperialism, we're partly,
uh, dreamed up in order to
explain that, that, that you get,
you get imperialism partly as a result
of the search for new markets to address
the endemic weak demand
in capitalist systems.
Marks is not the only person who
thought there was endemic weak demand in
capitalist systems.
Indeed, uh, canes, the,
the Great English economist of the
first half of the 20th century. And,
and the, the theorist
who's, whose ideas informed,
uh,
the policies to end the depression also
thought there was endemic weak demand in
capitalist systems because
of a diminishing marginal
propensity to consume.
Keynes's idea wise, if you have
no money and I give you a dollar,
you'll spend it. But if you have
$1 million and I give you a dollar,
you'll save it.
And so when you get into recessions,
the problem is weak demand.
And so you get the Keynesian
answer to a recession.
So depressions is to spend money at
the bottom with governments to do that
largely through borrowing. And
this is of course, what a first,
the George W.
Bush administration in its final year.
And then the Obama administration in
its first year have been doing a classic
Keynesian response to their risks.
The what's now being called the great
recession to prevent it from becoming a
great depression, namely the state
borrows money, tries to spend it in,
in the parts of the economy that will
stimulate demand and then we'll get the
economy going back up.
So again,
this is an example of marches,
chronic underestimation of the capacity
of the state to do things that will
stave off crises or manage crises or
prevent them from becoming catastrophic,
really bad. And so, uh, you know,
I think we've seen a vivid illustration
of that in the last couple of years.
Finally,
working class consciousness as all of
these other things were going on and
making the system,
you know,
creek at the joints and become
less and less functional.
Marx thought that,
um,
the workers would start to
become a class for itself.
The workers would start to see that
they were getting ripped off and,
uh, get angry about it, become mobilized.
And militant and reached the point where
they believe that they had nothing to
lose,
but they're chains.
Now there are two problems with
that. One, we already mentioned, uh,
on Monday or last Wednesday,
this is that Mark's was half right in
thinking that people judge their utility
by what others get.
They don't just ask the Reagan question,
am I better off than I was four years ago?
They do pay attention to what others get,
but they generally,
and this is the part where he was wrong.
I know a hundred years of industrial
sociology has now pretty much established
desk. They tend to compare themselves
to similarly situated people.
So workers in the auto industry compare
themselves to steelworkers or coworkers,
not,
um,
to the executives who run the
firms in which they actually work.
And that's true up and down
the occupational scale.
I think I mentioned, uh,
a professor will be much more upset to
learn that their salary is $5,000 less
than the professor in the next office.
Then they will be to learn that their
salary is $500,000 less than the attorney
who lives down the street.
People compare themselves to others,
but to similarly situated others not
to people very far from them in the
socioeconomic order.
And so that kind of
militancy doesn't eventuate.
More importantly,
Mark's actually conflates the relative
immiseration of the proletariat with the
absolute immiseration of the proletariat.
See if we went back
through the slides and we,
we went back to the discussion
of the theory of exploitation.
Remember when, when we, we did
that little exercise and we,
we saw that you would all actually agree
to be more exploited on his definition
than less exploited.
Um,
when you had the choice of either
going to a 10 hours working day, um,
with new technology or an 11
hours working day without it. Um,
but that measure was a relative measure.
It was what you get as a proportion of
the total surplus as compared with what
the capitalist gets.
It wasn't an absolute measure and we
saw that it's perfectly possible for the
rate of exploitation as
he defines it to go up.
While the level of wages remains
constant or even increases.
So wages might be going up as well
as exploitation at the same time.
Well, but if that's true, you never
going to reach absolute immiseration.
You're never going to actually reach the
point where we're workers are literally
falling into poverty.
And if it's the absolute immiseration
that has to trigger the militant action,
they're working class consciousness,
it's not going to happen.
And indeed,
here again,
Mark's greatly underestimated what
governments can do to make sure that the
workers don't reach the point
where they have nothing to lose.
But their chains.
In the 1950s a Marxian in English marks
in political economists called Ralph
Miliband, who son now is a British
cabinet member, by the way.
Um,
David Miliband and this is the likely
next leader of the Labour party after they
lose the elections in
May to a David Cameron,
uh,
David Miller band's father Ralph wrote
a book called the state in Capitalist
Society in the 1950s,
I think it was 1954 but don't
hold me to it in which he said,
the welfare state is
capitalism's best friend.
Okay.
You know, the right always
attacks the welfare state,
but it's capitalism's best friend because
it buys off working plus discontent.
And it ensures that workers have a stake
in the existing order and that they
will never reach this proverbial
situation where they have nothing to lose,
but they're chains.
So when you,
you work your way through
this macro theory,
it's riddled with holes and doesn't
add up to the collapse of capitalism.
And it not therefore
particularly surprising that
a capitalism didn't collapse
in the ways that Mark's predicted.
But now let's dig in a little bit
more to the micro theory and the micro
foundations of Marxists thinking
because I think this is where, um,
we will find,
uh,
some interesting lessons for our own
project in this course going forward.
At the heart of the micro theory
is the labor theory of value.
And we're going to say something
about three aspects of it.
We're going to talk about,
um,
Mark's assumptions about
living human labor,
the moral argument behind
the Labor theory of value,
which many people you
will find in this room,
find the POA despite the problems with
the labor theory of value and then some
alternative formulations of what
it is that he was trying to do.
If, if you think back to when
we were doing the exposition
of the Labor theory of
value,
I said that Mark's defends it living
human labor power as a source of value by
saying it's the only thing
that
goes into the production. It's the only
thing that creates fresh surplus value.
Okay.
So one difficulty is,
and John Roma points this out in
that piece that I had you read,
it ignores the contribution of
dead workers that living workers,
uh, for instance, we, when we talked
about the introduction of machinery,
the Spinning Jenny or whatever, what
about the workers who made the spinning?
Jenny,
are they part of this calculation?
Are they being either by the capitalist
or by the living workers who use the
Spinning Jenny?
So if you took it seriously,
you'd have to say those exploitation
indexes is way too simple because they
don't capture the
contribution of dead workers.
But then a second thing,
it doesn't capture the Labor theory of
value as soon as the capitalists can
contributes
what?
Nothing.
But why isn't it the case
that what the, the, the,
the Labor that the capitalists performs
also goes in to the creation of the
surplus. And again, I think
you've got to imagine,
get yourself back into
this 19th century mindset.
Her intellectual work doesn't
seem petty particularly important.
Um, you know, you're just running
these big factories. But of course,
you know, when we think
about what the, the, the,
the role of entrepreneurial ideas is
in the creation of productive systems.
It's absurd to say that the work of the
capitalist doesn't contribute anything
to the value of what's produced.
But then you get into the problem of,
well,
how do you discover what is,
what is the result of the work of the
worker and what is the result of the work
of the cap and list?
And there's no mechanism
for dealing with that.
And then
what about the fact that
the worker in March,
this typical model has a spouse at home
feeding him, uh, you know, uh,
sending him,
making his sandwiches as he goes to
the factory and so on and so forth.
What about the spouse at home?
Why is it just the worker
who's being exploited?
And
various theorists have said,
you know,
if you take Marxism seriously on its
own premises, it seems that, again,
just as with the dead worker,
the stay at home spouse is either being
exploited indirectly by the capitalist
or is being exploited by
the worker who goes to work.
She is doing unpaid labor.
And so we've had a series of feminist
critiques of the Labor theory of value
and
this gets recognized in daily life.
Uh, this, uh, very interesting,
1986 divorce case in the
state of New York in which,
uh,
a couple had gotten married.
He had gone to medical school,
she had stayed at and darn does socks and
made sandwiches for him and helped him
through medical school. Anyway,
many years later they get divorced.
And apart from the usual
issues in the divorce of, um,
the courts said that the stay at home wife
had a property interest in her
husband's medical practice.
That was a byproduct of the work that
she had put into it by darning socks and
making the sandwiches. And he went
to class and built up his practice.
And so they awarded her 40% property
interest in the practice and required him
to maintain life insurance in her name
for the rest of his life so that her
property interest could be protected.
So what you can see once you
start to do this, you know,
I've just given three areas
where this runs into trouble.
Once you take seriously the idea that
Labor is the source or labor power,
the capacity to work
is the source of value.
Why zero in men in this,
you know,
motto and I Echo y on what one worker
dies and the who in the production
process.
What about all of the others
who contribute to PR to
the productivity of the
process? Either directly as with
the capitalists will indirectly.
And of course, once you make this point
about the stay at home spouse, you know,
what about the Sunday school teacher
that drum the work ethic into the worker.
Um,
didn't that Sunday school
teacher contribute something
to the productivity of
the worker and so on. So
you're going to get, you know,
this huge web of indecipherable entangled,
um,
entitlements.
Um,
if you're trying to trace out who
contributed what work to the creation of
something of value,
okay,
more fundamentally,
let's dig into the assumption that
making creates entitlements
after all. For Marx, it's the,
it's this is what seems
to give the theory.
It's it's ideological edge. Uh, as I said,
it's a secular version of locks.
Workmanship.
It's the claim that work has produced
something for which they're are not
compensated. They produce
something and the capitalist
takes it, right. That's the,
that's the claim.
Okay.
And when we were doing
the exposition of that,
I said that what differentiates labor
power from all other commodities is that
it's necessary for the
production of every commodity.
It's the common denominator
of all commodities. Man,
by gave you the example, I said if I, um,
if I have a certain amount of
money and I spend it on a meal,
I consume the meal and it's gone.
Whereas if I spend it paying somebody
to paint my house at the end of having
consumed their labor power,
I have a more valuable house.
If I go to sell the house,
I'm going to get more from
it than I would have gotten.
But for having, uh, not ha
not having had it painted.
And so that's the idea that
the consumption of living
human labor power leads
the fresh ration of fresh exchange value.
Whereas media consumption
of a meal doesn't.
Yeah,
terrible argument.
What's wrong with it?
Nobody can see what's wrong with
it. Come on. It's terrible argument.
Hopelessly bad argument.
Anybody.
Yes ma'am.
Um, could the meals value be that it
keeps you alive? Say, say a little more.
You're dead right. Um, so the meal, even
though it's, you can only use it once,
um, it is necessary for this
sustained value of like yourself.
Okay. And, and what, but just take,
take that thought a little further.
Where does it go? Yeah, you're dead right.
Um,
so the valued is like constant,
well, not exactly, but the
point, is it just wrong?
Just say it and I can consume that food.
It goes because after all,
I have more calories of energy, which I
could then use to pay my own house with.
Right?
Let's say,
of course I might sit on the couch and
watch the Superbowl and just get fat,
but that's my own decision,
right? I can use that energy,
right. To paint the house and
saw a very interesting, um,
Cambridge economist called Pierre Ross
Rafa wrote a book called the production
of commodities by means of
commodities in the, uh, it's,
it's even though it's a s
it's about an 80 page book.
It took him 30 pages to 30 years to write.
Um,
and that's a whole different story,
which I have time to go into. But he,
this is what he, this is what he said,
that's of interest to us. He said,
imagine an economy that has
three commodities, corn, books,
food.
I'm sorry, corn books. Labor. Corn
is food, corn books and Viber.
Yes. It's true that it takes labor
to produce corn and to produce box.
Yes, it's true that it does not
take books to produce corn or labor,
but it's not true
that it doesn't require corn
to produce labor and books,
so corn or food or anything
that's necessary for the
production of labor power
is going to have the same
property that labor power has.
Its going to be present ness necessarily
directly or indirectly in all lines of
production and strokes.
Rafa said based on that idea you can,
you couldn't do a corn theory of value
for this economy that will have exactly
the same mathematical properties.
It's the labor theory of value
and then you can do the tea.
You can have your theory of the
exploitation of corn by capitol,
the rate of exploitation
of corn by capital.
That will be exactly analogous to the
rate of the exploitation of Labor by
Capitol. There is no difference,
mathematically identical.
Why is that interesting to us?
It's interesting to us because it
shows you that whatever mark says about
exploitation merely being a
technical notion, it's not,
it's a moral idea. We don't
care. You know, we do.
We even colloquially, we talk about
the exploitation of natural resources,
but we don't care.
We don't say that the corn owns
what was produced with the corn.
We don't sell,
we don't say the corn was exploited
in the way that worker was exploited.
We just don't
think about an intermediate case.
Okay.
A horse down a mine shaft
in a coal mine hauling
trucks have called from the face to the,
to the,
um, elevator that's going
to take it out. You know,
we could do the whole, he, the
story, we could say the, the,
the horse covers the cost of its
feed in the first hour of the day.
Uh,
and it works 10 hour days.
So the other nine hours it's producing
surplus that accrues to somebody other
than the horse.
It's the horse exploited.
Yes.
No,
nobody thinks that. Nobody thinks
of the horse. Is it an exploited,
some
much trickier case.
Right.
And the reason it's tricky is some
people are much more open to the idea of
animal rights than others, right? So,
you know, for block, Trina
said animals where there,
what waste of God put there for I use,
but we're not that hard hearted.
Some of us.
So if you think of of the horses in
some sense a kind of moral agent,
then it's,
it's not a happy thing that it's being,
it's being exploited in the sense,
but whether or not we want to say
the exploitation is on just not just,
just cruel if the horse is suffering.
But I'd just depends upon some prior idea
that people are,
or creatures are entitled to
the product of their labor.
Okay.
That's the workmanship idea.
And that is why even if you
reject the labor theory of value,
you're still left with this,
this nagging idea
that there's something to workmanship.
Most people are not gonna want to
totally get rid of workmanship.
You know, if I write a book,
I think I put all that blood,
sweat and tears into that
book. It's mine. It's mine.
My work. Somebody takes that.
You've stolen something that I made.
It's a very powerful thing in people,
but not everybody accepts it,
right?
Not Everybody accepts this idea,
this very individualistic sense
centric conception that we own.
What we make. We have this
kind of exclusive, uh,
to go back to the language of lock in
the first treaties that week. We are,
God made us with the capacity
to be miniature gods,
to have the same ownership rights of a
what we make as he has over his creation.
Look at chief Seattle.
He has a very different view.
This,
we know the earth does not belong to man.
Man belongs to the earth.
All things are connected like
the blood that unites us all.
Man did not weave the web of life.
He is married a strand in it.
Whatever he does to the web,
he does to himself.
Very different view of the world
and our place in it, right?
Not Man centric. And when we, when we,
one of the reasons we started
this course with lock,
it's this is where the individualism
comes from. It's this workmanship ideal.
Doesn't lucky individualist at all in
locks formulation because at the end of
the day, it's a theological argument.
It's an argument about lock, uh,
about God having owner make has
rights over his whole creation.
But it's the move of saying
we are miniature gods
that can behave in a godly
fashion and then secularizing it,
which,
which leads to the individualism or
consider something that Robert Nozick,
uh,
a writer we're going to read later in
the class pretty soon actually starting
next week.
He makes fun of the Labor theory of value.
He says, why does mixing once Labor
with something make one the owner of it.
Okay.
Behalfs paps because one owns one's labor,
self ownership if you lie.
And so one comes to own a previously
unknown thing that becomes permeated with
what one on ownership
seeps over into the rest.
But why isn't it,
why isn't mixing what I own with what?
I don't own a way of losing what I own
rather than of gaining what I don't know
if I own a can of tomato juice and spell
it into the sea so that its molecules
made re radioactive. So I can check
this mingle evenly throughout the sea.
Do I thereby come to own the sea or have
I foolishly dissipated my tomato juice?
Okay.
Why is it that we want to say,
when I made,
I put effort and energy into
something that it's mine.
Very, very perplexing and tricky
thing. And we will come back to it,
uh,
in,
in considerably more detail later in the
course when we read John Rawls because
interestingly,
it's not until we get to John Rawls that
we find anyone who's really willing to
radically question workmanship and the
self ownership postulate that goes with
it.
Okay.
So mark says,
I'm seems problematic.
So what's left, and I think there
are really two main things left.
One is a negative argument that comes
out of Marxism rather than any of its
positive, uh, claims.
And that is the fact that his theory of
exploitation fails doesn't mean that he
lacks a good critique of
markets as distributors, uh,
either goods or harms in society.
You know, we could go back to our
story about Trump and the bag lady,
for example.
Um,
the Paredo superior result in that
example of you remember wished for the bag
lady to die because there was no righto
x superior exchange that could occur
between Trump and the bag laggy markets.
Okay,
reflect the inequalities
that come in to them,
but they don't give any account of
the justice of those inequalities.
So as there's this problem, if you
like, of the tyranny of the status quo.
And we saw that in the economic realm
with the analysis of that problem and in
the political realm when we talked about
the the corn dealer problem with Mel,
right? That the market systems
of bias towards the status quo,
but market principles are
purely procedural principles.
They tell you nothing about
how you got the status quo.
And so there's a kind of garbage in
garbage out problem with market systems.
Nozick we will say makes
this point explicit when he
says any remotely plausible
theory of justice is going
to have to have three parts.
A theory of justice in acquisition,
a. I. E. A theory of starting points,
a theory of justice in transfer I a
theory of exchanges and the theory of the
rectification of past injustice.
I E F theory for dressing,
um,
accumulated injustices of the par paused
and Nozick well for reasons which we
will go into. Thanks. He has
accounts of all of those things,
but it's an the negative crap.
Um,
the negative argument of Marxism that
markets are not justified by reference to
the failure of marks or so an
alternative theory is good.
If you're going to have a justification
for the distribution that occurs through
markets,
it's gonna have to be something else.
It's gonna have to be provided.
Maybe it can be provided.
But so far in the utilitarian
and neo classical traditions,
it hasn't been provided.
So there's a kind of unfinished agenda
there that's put on the table by the,
the Marxian Critique of markets.
Um,
even though his answer to that,
his marks,
his answer to that problem
is, uh, I'm convincing.
And then I think secondly,
what Marx is,
I'm leaves us to address is not an
argument about the sources of value.
The labor theory of value is just
a hopeless analytical mass and uh,
can't be resuscitated. There's no
way to fix the labor theory of value.
Um,
but there is an argument about freedom.
Remember where we started?
I said,
unlike the conventional wisdom
that Marx is an egalitarian, no,
he's a theorist of freedom.
His Utopian ideal,
a world in which the free development
of each is the condition for the free
development of all where our
neighbor is not an alienated.
We saw that the Utopian version
of that is unsustainable.
Nonetheless.
Mark says definition of class.
When you think about it,
it's really an argument about freedom.
Yeah.
When do you say she,
you're working class.
If you have to sell your labor power
to somebody else in order to live,
it's the compulsion,
right?
It's a compulsion. It's not why
that you choose to, you know,
I liked lecturing here.
Having a captive audience of people
have to listen to me ramble on and dusty
makes me feel good, but that's
not what makes me working class.
Right?
It's that, that I have to work for
somebody else in order to survive.
It's that element of compulsion.
That's your lack of freedom.
And that is the so,
so as,
AS Roma puts it in the essay
that I put on the syllabus,
it's that some,
there's a class monopoly of the means
of production which creates that power
that some people have the power to
insist that other people work for them.
So it's really not about the
calculus of contributions and who,
what's what and you know,
whether the rate of exploitation
2.33 or 1.6 or anything,
it's not about that.
It's really about the distribution
of power in the production process.
And if we're going to take anything
from marks that is of enduring value,
it's going to be an argument about power.
It's going to be an argument which says
that a world in which we organize things
so that one class effectively has
power to control a different classes,
behavior that is an unjust world,
and much of the Neo Marxist
literature that, um,
okay.
People take seriously jettisons the
labor theory of value and explores this
power based argument as the root of what
it was Mark's was trying to get at with
the concept of exploitation.
See you on Monday.